[Music]
foreign
are you I steer a little but the
reindeer do my sword
this is my full fear of the center how
about you
started the whole damn thing
[Music]
we decided that you could have one gift
early
what is it that is a direct hotline
Santa Claus himself
all right revelers welcome to your worst
Christmas ever let's go
you have 300 million dollars in your
personal vault
for Christmas
[Music]
laughs
I don't want any trouble okay
Something's Gonna scooch up that chimney
who is he because he's not your typical
Mall Santa
[Music]
are you there
[Music]
my name is Judy likes soup
no I'm a nice list
Santa Claus is Coming to Town
season's beatings
who the hell are you
Boss what if he really is the real no
such thing as Santa
dude's Batman
they're all in my nylon naughty that's
naughty
and what do you do to the naughty ones I
give my lump a call
where is it
if I believe in you Santa
[Music]
which one of you did that Prancer
so unprofessional
[Music]
foreign
[Music]